the digestive system consists of
specialized organs and glands that
process food and Supply nutrients to
body cells the digestive organs form a
continuous tube called the
gastrointestinal tract
in normal digestion swallowed food moves
down the esophagus and into the stomach
where the food is broken down into
smaller particles from the stomach these
particles enter the small intestine
where enzymes from the pancreas liver
and the intestinal lining break down the
particles into nutrient molecules
along the lining of the small intestine
cellular projections called microvilli
absorb the nutrients as well as water
sugars and fats
unabsorbed food particles move into the
large intestine which absorbs more water
and salts the remaining material enters
the rectum where it will be stored until
it exits the body as Solid Waste called
feces
lactose intolerance is an example of
abnormal digestion
lactose is the major carbohydrate in
milk and milk products
normally ingestion of lactose stimulates
cells lining the small intestine to
secrete a digestive enzyme called
lactase lactase divides the lactose into
simple sugar molecules
which are easily absorbed
in lactose intolerance lactase is either
absent or insufficient after ingestion
of food containing lactose no lactase is
available to break it down
as a result lactose accumulates in the
small intestine which disrupts normal
water absorption causing water retention
the unabsorbed Water and undigested
lactose enter the large intestine
where bacteria metabolize the lactose
this process generates gas that fills
the large intestine causing abdominal
pain and flatulence in addition lactose
in the large intestine causes water
retention producing watery feces known
as diarrhea
while there is no cure for lactose
intolerance treatments include taking
lactase Tablets before eating foods
containing lactose using lactase enzyme
drops in milk and drinking lactose-free
milk